when it comes to inclusive language
oftentimes people tend to use phrases
like people with penises or people with
vaginas rather than saying male and
female are men and women while this can
absolutely be inclusive for trans people
unfortunately it's not always the most
inclusive language for intersex people
my advice is to use language that
focuses on function and not just form
that means focusing on the actual
function that you're talking about such
as people who can get pregnant people
who can get other people pregnant people
who are at risk of testicular cancer and
so on and so forth this is much more
inclusive because there are intersex
people who are born with the vagina but
don't have a uterus or ovaries or an
ability to menstruate i think that from
now on we should describe people by all
of their biological features all of them
so i think it should just get longer and
longer so it could be a person with a
penis but no testes
and also a uterus but a prostate like i
feel like that would be better than just
saying intersex people isn't what they
identify as the only thing that matters
why are we even trying to use objective
metrics like whether they are a person
who has a uterus in order to measure who
they truly are inside this lady is too
intolerant